it's torture
absolute
it's absolute torture
a mother emotional about the very
personal story of her daughter thank you
for joining us at six I'm Kirsten Joyce
and I'm Brian Loftus now she is the
mother of a woman Nathan chasing horses
accused of abusing for years she sat
down only with eight news now
investigator Vanessa Murphy who first
brought us the daughter story last night
Vanessa has been breaking stories about
the criminal case against the Dances
with Wolves actors here now with more
she lives with guilt every day but she's
now trying to stand up against the man
accused of victimizing her daughter I
want to let our viewers know this story
is of a sensitive nature
I tried to kill myself
I didn't see another way out because to
me leaving was never an option because
of my mom
what would happen if I left Melissa
Leone breaks down as her daughter Karena
shares her story saying she endured
sexual abuse to save her I wish I could
take it all back
and now looking back Melissa says she
realizes Nathan chasing horse was
grooming her daughter she says they
first met the self-proclaimed Medicine
Man and spiritual leader when karenna
was about six years old and he told me
um
certain things about uh
my own husband trying to make me see
like that there was no future or hope
she says she left her husband a decision
she now regrets I clicking back I wish I
wish he didn't let me move she says she
became devoted to chasing horses group
known as the circle do you believe it's
a cult absolutely
absolutely
I didn't see it as a call I was in there
Melissa says she was diagnosed with
cancer when Karena was 14 years old they
asked a chasing horse for help to heal
her Karena visited him and says he told
her spirits demanded her Purity to save
her mother and that's when she says he
sexually assaulted her for the first
time so what happened there was rape and
there's no other label to put on it she
says the sexual abuse continued and
chasing horse told her if she told
anyone her mother could no longer be
helped when she turned 16 they say he
asked Melissa if Corona could be his
wife I think I was so brainwashed by
then
I looked at it as some kind of Honor
that he chose my daughter
I was so sick in the head at that point
that it was an honor and I would walk
around the circle with almost kind of
feeling more entitled or privileged than
the other women when karenna turned 18
she says she moved in with chasing horse
as his seventh wife and the abuse now
also physical and verbal escalated she
says she escaped in late 2021 and slowly
began telling her mother what had
happened in January chasing horse was
arrested and he now faces 18 charges in
Clark County related to the alleged
abuse of two women Karena is one of them
and every day I have to wake up and
convince myself
today I'm a good mom
but it's really hard
when you know
the choice that you
made put her in there and I
didn't I didn't know I couldn't even get
her out I didn't know
chasing horse is expected to be back in
court here tomorrow he also faces
federal charges and warrants in Montana
and Canada these additional cases seem
to be in large part because karenna came
forward